[Music]
a short drive
from downtown boulder city the nevada
southern railway nevada state railway
museum
the rail line was constructed by the
union pacific railroad to
service the boulder dam project and it's
become quite a destination now for a
really fun outdoor activity it's just 30
minutes away from the las vegas strip
hector mejia takes us on board the rail
explorers a
pedal powered rail bike
have you ever thought about taking a
bike ride down train tracks
my inner child's going crazy right now i
used to love trains we're gonna have
so much fun today i just want to be able
to make it back
take a drive down to boulder city and
you'll find rail explorers
the hour and a half excursion promises
the magic of the railroad and nature
with a bit of history it's for all ages
we had a 95 year old lady who was
charged at the break and she goes i'm
peddling this thing i says you go
you have three different tours to choose
from daytime
sunset or an evening ride under the
shining stars
you don't really get to see all the
stars in vegas because it's so bright
the journey takes you on the same tracks
that were used for construction
of the hoover dam back in the 1930s in
an open air car
and then after we have a picnic area
then the historic boulder city train
that used to take everybody to the
hoover dam and all the workers all the
supplies that train comes to pick you up
and then you get to take the ride back
with covet 19 procedures in place
but i'm also the covet lady so we do the
check-in
and we have a couple questions back we
have hand sanitizers they disinfect
the bike we disinfect the chairs we
disinfect the train the restrooms
between each tour
i've never done something like like this
before at all
decided to celebrate our industry
tonight our 12 years anniversary
hector mejia reporting from boulder city
happy anniversary prices start at 85
dollars locals get a 10 percent discount
looks like a fun activity
socially distanced if you will